[Aplausos]
[Música]
el pasado 1 de julio de 2017 se celebró
un aniversario muy especial se
cumplieron 20 años desde que hong kong
dejó de ser parte del reino unido- y
volvió a formar parte de la república
popular de china bajo el modelo un país
dos sistemas como sabéis aunque china es
una dictadura hong kong se incorporó al
país como una región administrativa
especial donde rige la llamada 'ley
básica que les otorga a los ciudadanos
de hong kong un catálogo de derechos y
libertades inimaginables en el resto del
país con la excepción eso sí de macao
además amigos hong kong tiene su propia
moneda su propia política de inmigración
y también policía aduanas y tribunales
propios vamos que en el día a día
funciona casi como un país independiente
pero espera de un momento porque he
dicho casi la intromisión de pekín está
siendo cada vez más intensa y no penséis
que en pekín se andan con rodeos no
agentes secretos chinos han llegado a
secuestrar y torturar a activistas
prodemocracia de todo esto y de la
llamada revolución
paraguas nos habló ya couto aquí en
visual político a los pocos días
comenzaron las movilizaciones civiles
lideradas en un primer momento por
estudiantes algunos de apenas 17 años os
dejo el enlace al final del vídeo y
también en la descripción el caso es que
para celebrar este 20 aniversario o más
bien para dejar claro quién manda xi
jinping hizo su primera visita a hong
kong desde que es el presidente de chiná
xi jinping en hong kong pues bien la
visita de xi jinping a hong kong estuvo
cargada de simbolismo y es que se ha
producido en un momento en que las
críticas contra china arreglan el hong
kong la visita a amigos duró tres días y
en ese corto espacio de tiempo el
presidente chino se ha encargado de
dejar las cosas bastante claras
cualquier intento de poner en peligro la
soberanía y seguridad de china desafiar
el poder del gobierno central o usar
hong kong para llevar a cabo actividades
de infiltración y sabotaje contra el
continente es un acto que cruza la línea
roja y es absolutamente inadmisible
vamos en otras palabras que para pekín
todo eso de la libertad de expresión y
la democracia tiene límites y desde
luego no van a permitir que ningún
activista o político se desmadre y se le
ocurra poner en cuestión el control de
pekín
y ojo porque la acción de sillín ping no
se limitó ni mucho menos a esta amenaza
para nada
el presidente de china aprovechó también
su visita para presidir el mayor desfile
militar de la historia de hong kong con
tropas chinas claro y para asistir a la
toma de posesión de carril a la nueva
jefa ejecutiva de la ciudad lo que viene
a ser la presidenta de hong kong por así
decirlo pues bien sin fin como autoridad
superior aunque conforme a la ley básica
tiene prohibido interferir en la
política local
aprovecho para pedirle dos cosas a la
nueva jefa administrativa de hong kong
por un lado aprobar una ley anti
subversión para poder condenar a todos
los díscolos que se atrevan a defender
cosas como democracia o independencia
para hong kong y por otro un plan de
educación patriótica para los jóvenes si
tal cual como lo escucháis es lo que
tienen las dictaduras les gusta que los
niños estén bien enseñados en la
obediencia al régimen claro que los
hongkoneses no están precisamente por la
labor
a pesar de las advertencias del
presidente de china coincidiendo con su
visita el 1 de julio 60.000 personas
recorrieron las calles de la ciudad
pidiendo básicamente democracia y
garantías para preservar su grado de
libertad y la gente de hong kong no se
levanta por sí misma no sale a la calle
y pelea entonces hong kong se convertirá
en china así están las cosas en hong
kong y desde luego en visual político
estaremos muy atentos a cómo evolucionan
las cosas ya sabéis no olvidéis
suscribiros al canal para estar al tanto
pero llegados a este punto y dado que se
ha celebrado el 20 aniversario de la
soberanía china sobre la mesa hay una
pregunta que no podemos dejar de
hacernos una pregunta obligatoria qué
tal le ha ido a hong kong durante estos
20 años ha cambiado mucho en qué
situación se encuentra pues bien
veámoslo
[Música]
hong kong sigue siendo hong kong
tal vez la mejor noticia tras estos 20
años es que hong kong sigue siendo
simple y llanamente hong kong una ciudad
distinta al resto de china os lo digo
por experiencia propia es difícil
resistirse a esa mezcla de caos
capitalismo y cultura china que de forma
tan viva se respira en esta ciudad
[Música]
hong kong sigue siendo la ciudad más
rica y más libre de china sus tribunales
funcionan los medios de comunicación no
están sometidos a censura y el debate
político es animado tan animado que las
protestas contra chinas son habituales
de hecho ver una manifestación por la
libertad de más de 60.000 personas como
colofón a la visita de xi jinping es
buena muestra de ello
además amigos durante este tiempo el
crecimiento económico ha promediado un
respetable 3.3 por ciento anual un
crecimiento que aunque es algo inferior
al de otras potencias asiáticas como
singapur o no asiáticas como irlanda es
superior al que han tenido la mayoría de
las economías más ricas buena prueba de
ello es que durante este tiempo más de
un millón de chinos se han trasladado a
hong kong en busca de fortuna o también
que la ciudad haya logrado consolidar su
importancia como ciudad financiera
mundial el número de empresas que
cotizan en la bolsa de hong kong se ha
multiplicado por tres desde 1997 y su
capitalización alcanzó los 32 billones
de dólares en 2016 el equivalente casi a
todo el pib de alemania y además con
casi 60 millones de turistas que se dice
pronto hong kong se ha convertido en
toda una potencia en este sector claro
que esperando un momento porque también
hay síntomas de que el modelo de esta
ciudad puede estar agotándose
[Música]
y el ocaso de un modelo único
es verdad que el crecimiento económico
desde 1997 ha sido razonable pero
también es cierto que se ha ido
ralentizando que el ahorro se ha
desplomado y que el futuro no parece
ahora mismo el más halagüeño y no sólo
por la situación política la economía de
hong kong se enfrenta al peor momento en
20 años de hecho cada vez está más
extendida la sensación de que hong kong
no ha sabido reinventarse y que corre el
riesgo de convertirse en una especie de
parque temático para financieros y
turismo de poca monta tal vez donde
mejor se aprecia la pérdida de empuje de
la ciudad es cuando se la compara con el
resto de ciudades del delta del río de
las perlas la región a la que pertenece
hong kong y de la que tradicionalmente
ha sido el gran centro de actividad hoy
sencillamente ya no es así fijaos por
ejemplo en shenzhen
hace tres décadas esta ciudad china no
era más que un pobre pueblo pesquero de
50 mil habitantes
hoy es una impresionante ciudad donde
viven 15 millones de personas tiene
tantas compañías en el fortune 500 como
hong kong y es un destacado centro de
alta tecnología que alberga por ejemplo
a compañías tan importantes como tensen
o huawei pues ojo porque para muchos y
cada vez más
shenzhen y no hong kong está llamada a
ser la gran referencia de la zona y
atentos a este otro dato en 1997 hong
kong representaba el 20 por ciento de la
economía china hoy no llega al 3% así
están cambiando las cosas la economía de
hong kong está atascada apenas ha
cambiado en las últimas dos décadas y la
verdad no está especie de ocaso no tiene
nada que ver con la mala suerte hong
kong ha cometido importantes errores y
hay dos principales uno es el mercado de
la vivienda que es literalmente un
desastre
hong kong tiene unos precios
inmobiliarios tan disparatados que
muchos
los habitantes saben que su única
oportunidad es conseguir una vivienda
pública que probablemente sea minúscula
y es que pensad que en hong kong los
apartamentos de 40 metros cuadrados no
son algo extraño y claro cuando no hay
viviendas suficientes todos los espacios
inmobiliarios son carísimos y es difícil
acceder a ellos pues por ejemplo es
complicado que se instalen aquí startups
o nuevas empresas además todo esto hace
que ocurran cosas tan disparatadas como
esta se vende el garaje más caro de la
historia de hong kong por más de 600 mil
dólares ojo no es que no haya terreno
ese no es el problema menos del 25% de
la superficie de hong kong está
urbanizada y existen muchas más
posibilidades como la de ganar terreno
al mar no definitivamente ese no es el
principal problema mirad hong kong tiene
una economía muy libre si la más libre
del mundo según el índice de libertad
económica pero no lo es en absoluto si
hablamos de suelo vivienda y urbanismo
en hong kong el gobierno es el encargado
de llevar la batuta en el sector
inmobiliario y el fracaso que han tenido
en las últimas décadas ha sido de
escándalo hay más de 200 hectáreas de
tierra
disponibles para la construcción en las
zonas urbanas la escasez de viviendas es
real pero es debido a la deliberada
manipulación del mercado por parte del
gobierno fijaos bajo una política que
data de la etapa colonial hay
desarrollos inmobiliarios parados porque
el gobierno local arriendo por décadas
tierras a granjeros para plantar por
ejemplo arroz y hoy estas comunidades
apoyan a pekín y ningún gobierno quiere
problemas de locos y además también hay
claras sospechas de que se ha querido
favorecer a determinados oligarcas con
grandes propiedades inmobiliarias entre
los catorce magnates inmobiliarios más
ricos de asia 7 son de hong kong algunos
juicios y condenas han mostrado
evidencias de corrupción y confirmado
los muy sospechosos vínculos entre
funcionarios gubernamentales y magnates
inmobiliarios de hong kong
porque amigos este es el otro gran
problema de hong kong el creciente
capitalismo de amiguetes
[Música]
un futuro lleno de incógnitas
hay un consenso bastante amplio en los
últimos años el capitalismo en hong kong
ha perdido fuerza frente a una fórmula
con nombre similar pero muy diferente en
fondo y forma el capitalismo de
amiguetes
bajo los británicos el gobierno era pro
negocio pero no se inmiscuya en los
negocios desde 1997 los intereses
empresariales se han incorporado al
sistema político y los conflictos de
intereses se han multiplicado el
capitalismo de amiguetes ha crecido hoy
en muchos sectores la competencia ha
sido sustituida por oligopolios y
monopolios bien relacionados y lo peor
es que a medida que las autoridades
chinas ganan protagonismo en la ciudad
las cosas están yendo a peor por ejemplo
con la intención de ganar influencia y
peso político la llamada oficina de
enlace que viene a ser la representación
la delegación del gobierno chino está
incluso proporcionando préstamos en
condiciones ventajosas a las empresas
amigas y que es lo que necesitan estas
empresas amigas para recibir uno puedes
estar bien conectadas y para añadir más
sombras al futuro está sin duda el
conflicto político del que tanto os
hemos hablado
los jóvenes cada vez sienten menos lazos
de identidad con china pasa algo similar
a lo que ya os contamos sobre taiwán y
eso solo hace presagiar un debate
político más polarizado más caliente en
fin enfrentarse a todo esto es la misión
de carril am la nueva jefa ejecutiva de
hong kong claro que su legitimidad
parece dudosa al fin y al cabo ha sido
elegida no por el pueblo sino por un
grupo que responde a las directrices del
gobierno de pekín hubo un día amigos de
visual político que se pensó que hong
kong podría ser el modelo para el cambio
político en china hoy por desgracia las
cosas parecen algo diferentes y la
pregunta es cuál será el futuro de hong
kong ganaron las luces o las sombras
turno para ti puedes dejarnos tu opinión
como siempre los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta como siempre si te ha
resultado interesante este vídeo dale a
like un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]